so you said that the film to about 10
months did you start to piece together
the initial first edit with the
interview first and then peace in
archival footage or how did you do that
you piece together we we watched
everything and it took how like it took
a long time I'll months almost watched
all the footage and then we watched all
the archival footage that we had so it
was probably around 150 hours and with
our editor because she likes to watch
everything so um then we we kind of just
let I mean we pulled selects from
interviews from you know and then we we
kind of let our editor tackle it the way
she wanted to she generally cuts the
opening of the film first that's how she
works so that was what she cut first and
which wasn't that it's not an opening
did any of it it was a starting place
when we first saw it it was the opening
it was open to a long time yeah till
almost I mean through the rough cut yeah
um but then it changed but so she that's
how she starts um she's seen everything
and then she pieces together the opening
and that was the first thing we saw and
then she would do sequences we knew
there had to be a sequence about
spiritual midwifery we knew we wanted to
tell animes first first birth story we
knew that we had to touch on all the
historical aspects of the farm how it
came to be if the caravan we wanted to
introduce the other midwives you know
like we knew things that we had to touch
on so she would just kind of tackle
those bit by bit and and then and that
was for
time yeah and then it sort of got piece
together probably I mean six months
later you know it was like it was it was
really long process but um so that's how
she worked she she creates sequences she
did she and and as you can see in the
film it's really a weaving between past
and present so you know it would be like
we would touch on something historical
and then come to the present day and
trying to use as much verte as possible
there were a lot of interviews and our
whole intention when we began the film
was to make a Veritate film and then we
ended up with like 20 sit down in this
family wait this isn't what we wanted
but so you know she really has such a
kate amend who's this our amazing editor
has such a gift at pulling out verte
stuff that we wouldn't have dreamed
would be in the film is you know these
sort of offhand moments and um so that's
that's kind of how it started well what
was it about the initial rough cut
opening that made you backtrack and say
let's change it you know when we watched
it the first time when we went in and
sat down and watched it Mary and I both
had tears streaming down her face as we
loved it so much like it was just so
amazing to see all the rough footage
turned into what felt like a true
opening moment to us and we felt like
just so grateful to Kate for what she
had put together and and liked it and I
still like that i still like that
opening quite a bit but we showed it we
had a rough cut screening and people
were just not as like engaged in it for
the energy was like a little bit lower
um it was a more intimate sort of open
and I think probably what what I think
probably happened is that if you know
IMA and you know her work already she
has a charisma that pops off even
she's just sitting at her desk typing
but if you don't know who she is you
need to be sort of told right away that
she is the Rockstar Midwife that she is
and so that it was that shift in tone
that we felt like okay we've made a
quiet film let's not open it like so
quietly we need to give her like a
little bit of like we actually gave her
stage time you know like that the film
opens with her on stage talking to
people um so that if you weren't
immediately familiar with her you would
like get right away that like people
cared a lot about what this woman has to
say and the audience needed to know you
know that she lived on the farm and that
she delivered over a thousand babies in
that you know people felt like they
wanted to know so that they could like
sit back and relax and enjoy the movie
having that knowledge and so yeah like
so we felt like we had to just grow yeah
because they really i don't know way ha
yeah um who is this you know if for
people who didn't know her so so we
changed the open but we changed it very
late mm-hmm probably you know I don't
know towards the end yeah and then some
of the other shots you mentioned that
the graveyard shot and things like that
what was your decision behind not using
some of those said we had like a
three-hour rough cut probably at a
certain point and maybe maybe there's
like a two hour by the time we had like
larger groups of when that was still
yeah we had we had a few rough cut
screenings with documentary filmmakers
that that we knew and the K our editor
new and and it was we had sort of gotten
to that place where we weren't able to
see you know what was happening and and
so a lot of our decisions were made
taking their feedback into account I
mean we didn't take all the feedback
into account obviously but if we had a
couple of people who would say you know
i'm not sure why that's in there or it
didn't play the way he didn't
necessarily play the way we thought it
was playing if that came out more than
one or two or three times you know that
I thought had a big effect on I think
also get seen having been there you know
it was one of those moments as a
filmmaker where that was a very moving
moment just to be there and to have ina
may speak so candidly about experiences
in her life while standing in a cemetery
she talked about death and it was
beautiful the footage looked beautiful
and so we were quite attached to it for
those reasons and you know and when
somebody comes in and says I don't
understand why this is here and ended
consistently you know a number of people
saying that it's like you you have to
let go you know and so we're like okay
we'll just try try it to watch it
without it and then it never went back
in and there's a number of scenes and
some of them are on the DVD there are a
number of extras so and digitally you
can't let them also so a lot of the
scenes that work cut out making you know
we also had a goal of making the film 90
minutes so we felt we feel like that's a
good length for a documentary and much
longer than that is and on too long so
um you know all the non-essential scenes
that came out or now on a DVD so that's
really amazing to be able to offer them
to people even though they're not in the
filibuster we have we all along word
like posting on Facebook that the labor
analogy that sort of went with where we
were in the editing process of that
cutting was like you know trying to push
an 11-pound baby
you